The UN is in the news this week but not for keeping the peace.
It was revealed this week that one of the UN's unpaid interns...
...couldn't afford housing in Geneva,...
...so he did what any adventurous soul would do.
He slept in a tent.
Although David Hyde, the 22-year-old intern from New Zealand, knew the circumstances...
...when he accepted the role at the UN Conference...
...he's now calling for interns around the world to unite...
...to be counted and heard for their work,...
...even citing the UN's Universal Declaration of Human Rights as to why.
Now, maybe I'm a bit jaded.
I worked in the media industry for my entire career,...
...and the only way to break in was through unpaid internships.
You found stipends, you had side jobs, you babysat, you made it work.